[SPEAKER_04]: Accept the Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick comes back from being on deck back down into the cabins.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus, we've been on this, I've told you many times, we don't need to worry about these turtle dragons you've been talking about.
[SPEAKER_00]: Helm, Tyrus has been scared ever since we got on the water of when we sailed around that we run into turtle dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's why he's talking about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Waters look great.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think it's time I'll write this letter out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I may ask you something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_01]: He doesn't know all the information yet, so if we say anything about tracking, then he'll get on to it.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is it, lad, that you'd like to tell him?
[SPEAKER_01]: I was curious if
[SPEAKER_01]: You would be willing to let us see one of your letters from King James?
[SPEAKER_01]: James is a lord.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord James.
[SPEAKER_01]: My apologies.
[SPEAKER_01]: And no.
[SPEAKER_04]: He makes his lord into a thing and pulls out a bottle.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I'll drink with ya.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plop.
[SPEAKER_04]: I know that's your favorite.
[SPEAKER_02]: The lads better make sure the other side is clear.
[SPEAKER_02]: How is Carver?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's been a while.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tyrus and Merrick are whispering in the background.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just had to get that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll let you laugh.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, whatever you gotta do.
[SPEAKER_02]: I see the ghost on you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You got him drunk two days ago, didn't you?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's still recovering.
[SPEAKER_02]: Please, take a good hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: I take a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: I try to play it off as much as I can.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I roll for a performance?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do a con check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: And keep it down.
[SPEAKER_03]: Remember, there's five total.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lovely weather we're having, aren't we?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, yeah, it's been nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Except for the storms.
[SPEAKER_02]: Garden, remember that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Storms, yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: You see him swooping across.
[SPEAKER_04]: Weird this time of year.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, so what's the news out of Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_04]: How long have you guys, men, been out of there?
[SPEAKER_04]: I hear the city's dying.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not looking too good there.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not looking good.
[SPEAKER_04]: James doesn't tell me much.
[SPEAKER_04]: By the way, I do my rounds.
[SPEAKER_04]: I talk to the merchants.
[SPEAKER_04]: Most of the ships here don't want to be in Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_04]: They'd like to pass on to the city.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm the one that's been telling Jameis, why hasn't the fleet come down?
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what we want to know.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's his reply?
[SPEAKER_02]: Why hasn't he brought him?
[SPEAKER_02]: He tells me, wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: Those men of war.
[SPEAKER_04]: 400 marines on each.
[SPEAKER_04]: Easily taken care of by the squadron out of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: No doubt.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are these two trustworthy?
[SPEAKER_02]: I assume they are.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just a couple outside, a couple of more men of war that are outside.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know he's trustworthy.
[SPEAKER_02]: This young boy, you sure he's not a spy?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: See that pretty face?
[SPEAKER_03]: There's no way that pretty face could be a spy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Names Folsom.
[SPEAKER_01]: Captain Helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can call me Eric.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can't.
[SPEAKER_01]: I figured.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to say Captain Eric?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, Captain Helm.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eric Helm.
[SPEAKER_02]: Captain Helm.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, Captain Helm, tell me more.
[SPEAKER_02]: What?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, they got goods rotting on their ships here.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's all they have.
[SPEAKER_04]: It makes no sense.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's writing a long letter.
[SPEAKER_04]: I have my pigeon.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can carry it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think ink or lead weighs too much.
[SPEAKER_00]: Captain Helm.
[SPEAKER_03]: Come on, Merrick and Navy could take these men of war with no problem.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I mean, it'd be an effort, but not horrible.
[SPEAKER_04]: Easily done.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then why haven't they done it?
[SPEAKER_04]: I agree.
[SPEAKER_04]: Why haven't they?
[SPEAKER_04]: It seems like James has lost his balls.
[SPEAKER_03]: What would make Jameson lose his balls?
[SPEAKER_03]: Castration.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can't think of any.
[SPEAKER_02]: The man was a fierce lion in his day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_03]: Would anybody have something to hold Jamison back?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, he's a shrewd tactician and he knows more than me.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm sure he's got his reasons.
[SPEAKER_04]: Although I can't see what they are.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: But what...
[SPEAKER_03]: What would cause Monmurg to lose this much money and be worth it in the end?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, do you think there's a hook?
[SPEAKER_03]: I know there's a hook.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's gotta be a hook.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you think he's playing off Prince Jean?
[SPEAKER_03]: He's playing somebody.
[SPEAKER_03]: If he's that good, he's playing somebody.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, the only person I could see be playing was Prince Jean.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is treason words.
[SPEAKER_03]: Would losing all of this commerce be worth that?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's what I want to know.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's worth losing all of this commerce?
[SPEAKER_02]: What is the long game for that?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think it's losing commerce.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it's losing supplies.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, the supplies, which feeds his...
[SPEAKER_03]: Starving the city.
[SPEAKER_03]: But starving the city, there has to be a reason why he's letting this go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Either A, somebody has something over him.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's holding him back.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or B, he's playing a longer game than they are.
[SPEAKER_03]: Which one is it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Could be he's holding back the fleet for defenses.
[SPEAKER_02]: Know something that might be coming.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're talking miles away.
[SPEAKER_03]: The fleet could get there and back in no time.
[SPEAKER_03]: To crack the city walls, to crack the city of Monmurg, what would you have?
[SPEAKER_03]: What fleet could attack the city of Monmurg that the Monmurg fleet couldn't get back to?
[SPEAKER_03]: This is the question we need to figure out.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is the question.
[SPEAKER_04]: You know very well, Tyrus, that there's no fleet on the sea that can defeat Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Especially when the Outer Isles are with it.
[SPEAKER_04]: The secret?
[SPEAKER_04]: I won't read it, I'll watch you attach it to the pigeon myself.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you guys go out.
[SPEAKER_04]: He goes down into the hole and gets the pigeon, and without reading the deal, ties it up, and then it flies away.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he says...
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_04]: I will get a message back, but not that way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't believe so.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you'll get a message back.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll get information back, but not that way.
[SPEAKER_04]: And we'll know in a few days what the deal is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_03]: But in the meantime, I'm not a spy.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not one of these, but I want to know what is going on here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, actually, in the meantime, what you're going to do is go down in the bilge and bucket out enough water so you can sleep down there nicely.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what you'll do.
[SPEAKER_04]: You'll stay out of sight, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm out of sight, but I want to have a conversation.
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you guys know that why is this happening?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think you are Brian.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_00]: What do I know?
[SPEAKER_02]: All of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You, you, you, and you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everybody, why is this happening?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to hear about the rumors I've heard?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Duke of Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Duke of Gratzel wants a wife.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's all over a fucking woman.
[SPEAKER_04]: Of course it is.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Duke of Gratzel, in Keoland, wants a wife.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not just any wife.
[SPEAKER_04]: Whose wife?
[SPEAKER_04]: He wants a pure-blood soul wife.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you don't find those very often, not even in Keoland, even though there's four houses.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or three houses.
[SPEAKER_04]: The other two houses don't like Gratzel very much because they're so powerful.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so where do you look?
[SPEAKER_02]: Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: You look in Portoli.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which is the other side of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right?
[SPEAKER_04]: So the Duke of Gratzel is willing to cut a deal with the Toli.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the deal is this.
[SPEAKER_04]: They get a woman from their bloodline into Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right?
[SPEAKER_04]: And he helps them with the political problems with Lord Jameis.
[SPEAKER_04]: Slurgood.
[SPEAKER_04]: What?
[SPEAKER_02]: Now we getting somewhere.
[SPEAKER_04]: And there's an alliance between the House of Toli and the House of Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now we're getting somewhere.
[SPEAKER_04]: So this is an attempt to unify the kingdoms and not for us Iradians.
[SPEAKER_04]: And who stands in the way?
[SPEAKER_04]: The richest man in the world, Gion.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why would Gion care if there's a Seul woman in it?
[SPEAKER_04]: From House Toli?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: The principalities?
[SPEAKER_04]: Are you crazy?
[SPEAKER_04]: With Keoland's armies and ports of Toli, they'd have a place to march their armies right at the Monmurg whenever they wanted to.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, it's all over this.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Toli and the House of Rola from Gratzel have been at odds for hundreds of years before the principalities have ever been powerful.
[SPEAKER_04]: And now that Gion has finally gotten to the point where he's richer and more powerful than any man in the principalities, they need to nerf him.
[SPEAKER_04]: He needs to be taken down a notch.
[SPEAKER_03]: So really, this is all just to get
[SPEAKER_03]: Gion down.
[SPEAKER_03]: They get a woman, Sioux woman, now all of a sudden...
[SPEAKER_03]: They create an alliance.
[SPEAKER_02]: They make their bloodlines bingled.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now we can take Gion down.
[SPEAKER_02]: One of the princes.
[SPEAKER_02]: The most powerful prince.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, but the Outer Island princes would never go for this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: The point is...
[SPEAKER_03]: Now we, like, finally have a...
[SPEAKER_03]: So, are there rumors?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do they have a woman picked?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I'm sure they do.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where's she at?
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably Portoli.
[SPEAKER_03]: And What's-His-Name was going east for what reason?
[SPEAKER_03]: Who's What's-His-Name?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think the pigeon knows that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I'm going to stop it here.